enfin cessez le feu les négociations
tripartites avait débuté ce vendredi à
moscou
incluant les chefs des diplomaties russe
et arménienne et azerbaïdjanaise
après plus de dix heures de discussions
elles ont finalement débouché tard dans
la nuit sur un accord pour cesser dès ce
samedi les affrontements meurtriers qui
dure depuis près de deux semaines pour
le après de longues négociations nous
avons convenu et adopté le document
suivant le site
en réponse à un appel du président russe
vladimir poutine et conformément aux
accords conclus entre le président russe
vladimir poutine le président aliyev et
le premier ministre pashinian les
parties ont convenu les mesures
suivantes un cessez-le-feu est annoncé à
partir de 12 heures le 10 octobre à des
fins humanitaires
ceux du neuf new line août du certeurope
ciblées pour échanger les prisonniers de
guerre et autres personnes détenues
ainsi que les corps des personnes tuées
et ce conformément aux principes de la
croix-rouge justice
bakou avait montré les muscles d'entrée
ces négociations étaient la dernière
chance pour parvenir à une résolution
pacifique du conflit
dans le même temps le premier ministre
arménien nikol pashinian s'était dit
prêt je cite pour la reprise du
processus de paix
cette trêve fragile selon les dires de
paris vendredi doit désormais ouvrir de
nouvelles salves de négociation pour
tendre vers une paix plus pérenne ce
n'est pas la nôtre
les dispositions précises du
cessez-le-feu seront convenues
ultérieurement pour l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie avec l'intermédiation du
groupe de minsk de l'osce c'est eux
sur la base des principes fondamentaux
s'attelleront à des négociations de fond
pour parvenir à un règlement pacifique
dès que possible les choux de génie
murnau reste désormais à savoir si cet
accord sera bel et bien respecté sur le
terrain où plus de 400 personnes dont
plusieurs dizaines de civils ont trouvé
la mort depuis la reprise des combats
selon le dernier bilan officiel